LIV WU: Hi, everybody.
Thank you for coming.
I'm Liv Wu on the Global
Food team.
I just spent a very enjoyable
hour having lunch with Pati,
who I'm delighted to have
here, talking about
all sorts of things.
And in particular, about this
beautiful book, her cookbook.
But she has a breadth
of knowledge.
She is a political scientist and
interested in furthering
democracy and immigration
issues.
But I think the force and the
pull of her family finally
brought her back to food.
There are three other
people, her sisters,
who are also in food.
And it's what she's come back
to, with this wonderful
background that she has.
And I think probably the one
thing I'll tell you from our
luncheon conversation that was
so striking is that she's just
real, just like all these
recipes that'll work for you.
She's raising three boys.
And I raised one boy, and that
was enough for me, but anyway.
And she knows what they like
to eat and how to cook for
them and how to take
them out to eat.
And so this cookbook is totally
accessible, and
largely because of
the force of her
personality and her family.
So I'm just going to
give her the floor.
Welcome.
PATI JINICH: Thank
you so much.
Thank you so much.
You have no idea how I've been
looking forward to this day,
because I use Google a
thousand times a day.
So, so nice to be here inside
Google with all of you.
Such an incredible team
and incredible people.
And I just had the most
fabulous lunch.
I kept saying, get
out, really?
Get out, really?
They gave me a tour of the
kitchen, and they're making
their own Mexican-style
chorizo.
I would have stayed there, but
I had to come talk to you,
which I'm delighted about.
So I'll tell you a little bit
about my story, and then
afterwards, please,
if you have any
questions, let me know.
I wanted to begin by telling you
a little bit of the roots
of this book and where the
contents come from.
And I'll start with something
that happened to me after I
moved from Mexico.
I got married, move to Dallas,
Texas, and I was going to be
there just for a couple of
years with my husband.
And then we decided to stay
longer, and I got pregnant and
had my firstborn.
And when my mother realized that
I was not going to come
back to Mexico soon, or maybe
for a few more years or more,
she got really sad, because
she was really missing me.
And she told me something, as
we sometimes do, we tell
things to our kids that we
regret, and they're a little
bit hurtful.
And she said, you know, trying
to make me feel guilty and
wanting me to come back to
Mexico, she said, you know
what you've become?
And I said, what?
And she said, a despatriada.
Which is--
I mean, it makes my skin, as we
say in Mexico, have piel de
gallina, con los pieles de
gallina, like the hairs go up.
Despatriada is a really strong
word, let me tell you.
Despatriada means that you have
no roots, that you've
lost your patria,
your country.
That you're sort of
floating around.
And that was very
hard to swallow.
And then, of course, thought,
oh, she misses me terribly.
And it take many years for me
to understand that she said
that because she missed me.
And that I have really strong
roots to my home country, and
I have really strong roots
to my new home country,
which I also love.
So I am happily torn between
the US and Mexico.
And what happened--
and this is what
brought me into cooking--
I started political science.
I wanted to be an academic.
I grew up being an idealist.
And my parents were
even concerned.
I struck conversation with just
about anyone who would
share a little bit
of their story.
And when I moved to Texas after
having studied political
science, and wanted to be an
academic and work in a think
tank, I became insanely
nostalgic about Mexico.
I was newly wed.
My husband was traveling all
over, working a lot.
I was writing write my
dissertation on Mexican
democracy, which took
many, many years.
And I was insanely nostalgic,
and I started cooking.
I've always been a big eater,
but I had never been a cook.
I was a terrible cook.
I just think about the things
I put my husband through.
He ate some crazy meals,
let me tell you.
But so I started to cook, and
then I started hunting down
Mexican ingredients.
And it was that distance from
my home country that made me
perceive its food dimension, and
all the ingredients under
a new light, and seeing how
exotic and beautiful and
gorgeous and sophisticated
it is.
I grew up with tomatillos and
avocados and chiles every day.
Now when I found them in the
Latino aisle of a store, or a
little Asian store, I would go,
oh my god, the tomatillo
and the chile, and I would
romanticize about it.
And started making all the foods
that I grew up eating,
which make me feel at home.
It made me feel nurtured.
It made me feel warm and cozy.
Started making all that.
But I kept on studying political
science, because as
my father would say--
I mean, of course I flirted with
food so many times before
I decided to take the plunge.
My father would say, Pati, we
put you through college, and
now you're going to
go wash dishes?
So I kept on studying,
kept on working.
And then we moved to
Washington, DC.
And further studied and worked
at a think tank, which I
really admire, the Inter
American Dialogue, which was
fabulous work, with
the relations
between US and Mexico.
And I was still crazy
about the food.
And my husband kept on
poking fun of me, and
he would quiz me.
OK, Pati, you're a political
analyst.
Who's the president of France?
You know?
Because all I read was the food
section and cookbooks.
And I would be cooking
all the time.
And I would be really unhappy at
work, thinking, I just need
to put a little more
effort and get
involved in more projects.
And the thing that really
was pulling me was food.
So after thinking a lot about
it and struggling--
you know, because I think we
all have expectations of
ourselves, and the people that
surround us have expectations
of ourselves.
And I saw myself as an academic
with glasses, writing
articles that would help with a
small grain of salt or sand,
as we say in Mexico--
[SPEAKING SPANISH]--
to contribute to the
strengthening of democratic
institutions, et cetera,
et cetera.
And I decided to take the
plunge and resign, and I
enlisted to an intensive
course at L'Academie de
Cuisine, which is a
cooking school in
Gaithersburg, Maryland.
I had done it once before, when
I had been on maternity
leave with my second son.
And I decided to do it again, to
test the waters, and see if
I really wanted to do it.
And oh boy, did I really
want to do it.
I just, I went crazy.
And since then, I haven't
looked back.
And I've never worked
as hard in my life.
It's funny, because people say
you should do what you love
and be passionate about
what you love, and it
really takes over.
And it's really taken over, and
I sometimes have to stop.
My husband's like, Pati,
it's Sunday.
So in this book, you will
find those two roots.
I tried to show Mexican home
cooking, and recipes and
ingredients that may be already
very familiar to
Americans from both routes.
The traditional foods and dishes
that I grew up eating,
and that I love and that I
miss, and many that I've
gotten through requests
from the blog or my
classes or the PBS show.
And I feel that by doing that,
I help find those links that
sometimes are missing from
that chain that connects
communities and families, to
continue passing them on.
But you will also find recipes
and dishes and stories of me
testing those ingredients
and those dishes
in my American kitchen.
Sort of testing the limits,
expanding the uses of those
ingredients.
And I try to do it in a genuine
way, respecting the
soul of the ingredient and the
dish, or whatever I may be
playing with.
But sort of helping, again, like
with my small grain of
sand, to continue to expand
Mexican cooking, as many cooks
and chefs are doing
around the world.
So you will find the traditional
and sort of the
innovative.
And then as far as the stories,
I try to share not
only how to make a certain dish
or how to use a certain
ingredient, but I think that
Mexico and the United States,
we think we know each other,
and you know, we have that
huge border between each other
that connects us, but I think
there's so many things that
we're missing out.
And let me tell you,
I've been the very
first one to be humbled.
When I moved to the US, I always
thought, oh, Mexico, we
have the centuries of history,
and infusions of other
countries and ingredients
and so much richness.
And the US is such a young
country, when you compare it
to the pre-Hispanic Mexico.
I used to think that food and
the culinary world in the US
was going to be much more
shallow than it is, and that
there weren't going
to be the 32
original cuisines of Mexico.
And I really think there's
dozens and dozens more.
I've been humbled
time and again.
I mean, I went to Memphis--
I couldn't believe the food, the
culture, the specialties.
Everywhere I go, I've become
really, again, humbled about
how little I know of
my new country.
And now I'm super curious.
I'm dying to go to Nashville,
for one thing.
New Orleans, for another.
I want to come to San
Francisco for
more than one day.
You know, I just, I realize,
as a Mexican, how little I
know of the US.
And I think it goes the
other way around.
People think they know
Mexican food.
And I think the US, and the
world, really doesn't.
If the few dishes that have
crossed the border and have
become like crazily popular
that everybody knows.
But not many people know that
in Mexico, we're crazy about
salads, for example.
We just don't call it such.
We were talking before about
how in Mexico, I think, we
haven't done such stark or
marked categorizations or
compartmentalizations.
You know, the words vegetarian
and vegan.
I was talking to my editor when
we were writing the book.
I was really lucky.
I had this fabulous editor who
helped me sort of give
direction to the book.
And she was saying, Pati,
let's do a chapter on
vegetarian food.
And I jumped up--
I'm like, no!
Vegetarian, what do you mean?
No, no, I eat chorizo.
I eat bacon.
Chilorio.
Huevos con chorizo.
No, there's no way I'm going to
go do a vegetarian chapter.
And then I realized all the
foods that I eat that are
vegetarian or vegan.
Naturally, the Mexican diet was
mainly a vegetarian diet
before the Spanish arrived and
brought the pork and the
lard-- which we of
course love--
and so many other ingredients.
But we just don't
call them that.
So the example about salads--
we eat, for example,
cactus petal salad.
Let me tell you about
an ingredient
that's going to go wild.
Remember how portobello
mushrooms were all the rage
for vegetarians?
Just wait until cactus petals
start being sold clean.
Because the hassle is to get
rid of the spinas, or the
little thorns.
They're very persnickety
and hard to clean.
But cactus petals, oh my god!
They're wholesome, nutritious.
They're tart, they're chewy,
their mealy, they're
incredibly delicious.
You can use them in a thousand
different ways.
And just like the cactus
petals, there's so many
ingredients that people may find
in the supermarkets but
they don't know how to use them
or what to use them for.
Jicamas, chayote squash, all
different kinds of tomatoes,
and the tomatillo.
Everybody knows the salsa
verde and has
tried a salsa verde.
But not many people know that
all you need is a pound of
those tomatillos that come
covered in that husk.
And people are a little
intimidated, but you just peel
them, boil them, drop a chile,
drop an onion, throw it in a
blender, you have salsa verde.
So I think I'm trying to build
a bridge in whichever way I
can, to say, hey, you already
have all these things here.
They can give you so much power
in your own kitchen.
It's about empowering those
connections and those things
that we now share, thankfully.
Because now you can find any
ingredient that you want
that's used in Mexican cooking,
either if not in your
corner store, with the click
of an online button.
And so try to share, you know,
you're going to bring the
tomatillos into your house.
Let me tell you how you find
them, where they come, how
they've been used, how they've
been used throughout history.
And I don't want to bog people
down with so much history, but
hey, you can make salsa verde.
You can make a salad
using it fresh.
You can make a jam.
And I'll give you an example
of how distance has been a
blessing and a curse.
So I miss my family terribly.
I do, horribly.
My kids--
I have three boys.
They have so many cousins in
Mexico who they love seeing
and playing with all the time.
But wait, I wasn't going
to talk about my boys.
I was going to say the
tomatillo, which I'm
passionate about, it is just
such a gorgeous fruit.
In Mexico, tomatillos are mainly
used to make a salsa
verde, a cooked salsa verde.
It's very rare to find the
tomatillo used raw.
There's a few salsas here and
there, but not like raw,
chopped in a salad.
It's a very new thing.
So when I was coming up with
more recipes for the book,
like new spins on ingredients,
one summer it was really hot.
I had a really ripe, fresh,
super juicy, sweet watermelon.
And I was trying to come
up with a salad.
And I thought, oh my god, the
perfect thing would be the
tomatillos.
They're hard.
They're tart--
uniquely tart, because you can
find nothing too match that
flavor of the tomatillo.
Not green tomatoes, guys.
It's a different things.
In a pinch, you can substitute,
but a tomatillo's
a tomatillo.
So I thought, that's
a great contrast.
And I came up with a
vinaigrette, jalapeno and
mint, and some feta
cheese in there.
So I was telling my mom all
about this salad one day, and
she's like, Pati,
raw tomatillo?
Yuck, no!
No, no, we use it cooked!
It's in salsas.
And I'm like Ma, you won't
believe this salad.
No.
No way.
There's no way.
She comes visit, what
do I give her?
The watermelon and
tomatillo salad.
Who's making it in her
house in Mexico City?
My mom.
So it's that distance that has
given me, at the same time,
the nostalgia, that really,
really heavy nostalgia--
which can be beautiful, when
it's so heavy sometimes.
But the freedom to play and to
test those ingredients and
those dishes.
I've been talking too long.
Should I take some questions?
AUDIENCE: Hello.
PATI JINICH: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I've got four younger
children that age from
ten down to four.
PATI JINICH: Four?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Ten, eight, six,
four years old.
What recipes do your boys
like to make with you?
Or what's a good one
for the children?
PATI JINICH: Let me tell
you, Mexican food
is perfect for kids.
Perfect.
Because it's accommodating, it's
versatile, it's easy, and
the kids can participate.
I'll tell you something funny,
and then I'll tell you when
you can feed your kids.
I always like to compare the
food of a place to its people.
So you know, the French.
Think about French food.
It's a little bit fussy.
It's a little bit like,
things have to--
I love France.
I would go to Paris tomorrow.
I love French food.
But they're a little fussy.
You know?
Everything has to be perfect.
And think about what they
do to tomatoes.
When they're going to use a
tomato and it's going to be
cooked, they boil it for
just enough minutes.
Then they take it out, then they
peel it, then they core
it, then they seed it.
Then they cut in perfect
little squares.
What do Mexicans do with
tomatoes for a sauce?
We boil it and we throw the
entire thing in the blender.
With the seeds, with the
skin, with the core.
I love the tart flavor of seeds,
so as many Mexicans.
So I think just to tell you how
easy this book is going to
be for you--
you're not going to have to
peel and core and seed and
dice in perfect little
squares.
My kids love chicken tinga.
They love chicken tinga.
It's something you can pull
together in half an hour.
You can make it with chicken
that you cook at home or with
rotisserie chicken.
You make a big batch, and one
day you serve it was rice.
A couple of days later,
Wednesday comes, what do we
have for dinner, kids?
Tingadillas, quesadillas with
chicken tinga, which is
incredible.
You have a little
bit left over.
Friday, you can make some tortas
or some sandwiches.
The great thing is that many
of the food here--
another one is chilorio.
Chilorio is like a similar take
on the tings, in that
it's shredded meat.
This time, pork, but you can
make it with chicken, too.
It's a sauced-up, sort of drier,
moist stew that is
super versatile and
accommodating, like us Mexicans.
You can eat it on top of rice.
You can eat it in quesadillas,
in tortas, in molletes.
So those things you can make
ahead, you can make them on a
Sunday and then eat them.
My kids love making the piggy
cookies that are in here.
AUDIENCE: Well, my kids
love chicken.
So I know [INAUDIBLE].
PATI JINICH: They
love chicken?
AUDIENCE: I notice--
how much of the cooking
is between the men and
the women in Mexico?
PATI JINICH: That's
a good question.
We're getting political.
I used to do political
analysis.
There's a reason why I got out
of political analysis, though.
You know, most of the
cooking is done by
women, I think, in Mexico.
It's sort of a new thing, and if
you think about the leading
people in the culinary world,
professionally in Mexico, it
used to be mostly
women, The grand
dames of Mexican cooking.
Diana Kennedy to begin with.
She's British, but she
rules, like a British
woman should do.
Patricia Quintana,
Monica Patino--
I mean, there's so many-- there
was like a cadre of
women who ruled the
culinary world.
And it's been, I think, the
past generation, like this
generation, the past 15 years,
that men have entered and
really broken the perception
that it should only be women.
And they're doing crazy fun
things, testing and playing
with ingredients and
the concepts.
But it has been mainly women.
And in the homes, it's
also mainly women.
I can tell you, in my house,
it's mainly a women thing.
When I got married, and I met my
husband, I asked him on our
first date, do you
like to cook?
And he said, of course.
And I said, so what
do you cook?
And he said, soup,
chicken, salad.
I've never seen a soup.
I've never seen a chicken.
I've never seen a salad.
[LAUGHTER]
PATI JINICH: I've never
seen the pouring of
cereal into a bowl.
But I love you him so,
and he will eat
everything that I give him.
I can keep on talking.
Yes?
I'll tell you more theories
about what my
boys like to eat.
Anything that's sweet.
My little one, he's wild about
chipotles in adobo.
You guys familiar with
chipotles in adobo?
Yes.
No?
Yes?
Oh my god.
OK.
You have to try that.
And you buy it in the store.
It comes in a can.
You can make them by
yourself, too.
See, this is a great thing about
Mexican cooking, and why
I think-- you know, many people
think about Mexican
cooking, and it's either--
they think it's very spicy,
which it's not.
First of all, not all
of the dishes or
recipes or food are spicy.
Or not all of the chiles
are spicy.
There's like 100 different
kinds of fresh and dried
chiles, and I would say like
maybe 80% are super mild.
Chiles, think about
the poblano chile.
Who knows the poblano chile?
Yeah?
I love poblanos.
I'm infatuated with them.
They're so gorgeous.
They're green, they're plump,
they're curvy, their meaty,
they're delicious, they're
shiny, they're incredible.
And you can find them in the US,
which you couldn't when I
first moved to Dallas.
They're vegetables.
I mean really, they're
a gigantic chile.
And I think people are
intimidated because of the
word chile.
But I like to refer to poblano
chiles as vegetables with a
load full of personality.
You can use them-- you stuff
with cheese, with meat.
You can make rajas with them,
for eggs, for so many things.
So there.
We dealt with the first myth of
Mexican cooking, that it's
always spicy.
It's not.
The second myth about Mexican
cooking, I think, is that it's
very laborious.
So we do have phenomenal dishes
like the mole poblano,
or you know, that laborious
sauce to make.
Or the chiles en nogada, which
are such an artistic creation.
Who's heard about the
chiles en nogada?
OK.
It's poblano chiles that are
charred and sorted and
cleaned, and stuffed with meat
that's cooked in a mix of
tomatoes and onion and garlic.
And I know you guys
had lunch--
I hope I'm not going to
make you hungry again.
The meat is cooked with tomatoes
and onion and garlic,
and olives and capers
and raisins and
dried and fresh fruit.
Talk about the combination of
cultures, with Spanish.
OK, so those chiles are stuffed,
and then they're
bathed with this walnut
creamy sauce.
And that's not all.
Then they're garnished with
pomegranate seeds.
They're to die for.
They're incredible.
They're baroque, and they're
from a time in Mexico's
history that was very baroque.
Those dishes are like on one
end of the spectrum.
We eat them for holidays,
for weddings, for
Independence Day.
You eat them at a certain times
or on certain occasions.
But most of the cooking in
Mexico is home cooking, and
it's super simple and
easy to make.
You have tons of soups and
pastas and rice dishes and
salads and vegetable sides
that are very easy.
So they haven't become
very popular.
What I'm trying to do--
just because those
things stand out.
And so that's one myth.
Then that's the other myth.
Another myth--
and I'll stop at the third,
but I can just go on--
is that Mexican food is
like Tex-Mex food.
Or very greasy, cheesy,
creamy.
I love Tex-Mex food.
I'll lick the plate of
a combo platter.
And I recognize what it is.
It's a kind of regional food
from the US, and there's
wonderful things about it, but
it's not Mexican food.
There's so many different layers
and things inside of
Mexican cooking, which is what
I am trying to do in here.
Wait!
I had started talking about the
chipotles in adobo sauce,
and I never got to that.
Wait, can I tell you about
the chipotle sauce?
In adobo?
The chipotles in adobo?
OK.
So my youngest son
is crazy about
chipotles in adobo sauce.
They come in cans, and what they
are-- you all need to go
and get some.
What they are, it's jalapeno.
So everybody knows a
jalapeno, right?
A chipotle--
which is a beautiful name,
I think, chipotle--
is a jalapeno that
has been picked
when it's at its ripest.
So not green, but red.
And then it's dried.
And then it's smoked.
So can you imagine if all
that flavor is super
concentrated, OK?
And smoky, super smoky
and rustic.
Think of a chile
in cowboy land.
You have the chipotle.
Then that chile is pickled
in an adobo sauce.
The adobo sauce has vinegar and
spices and tomatoes and--
I found out--
ancho chiles, too.
So think about it.
A chile is being pickled
in another chile.
How crazy is that?
Spectacular.
Because the chipotle, it's smoky
and it's super spicy.
And the ancho chile that it's
pickled in is chocolatey, and
it's bittersweet, and it
has a taste of prunes.
So you have this condiment
that's incredible, and you
already buy it in
a can, right?
And you can use that
for so many things.
So that's one ingredient that
you are going to have to get
to make the chicken tinga.
Because it's in the chicken
tinga recipe.
But you can get it online with
the click of a button.
You can get it at the
grocery store.
And I'll tell you something.
You can make your own.
And you know how I found out?
Because of a request
that I got from
a woman from Australia.
So having this blog and this
site has really been an
enriching and incredible
experience for me.
Because first I started
getting requests from
nostalgic Mexicans like me.
I started teaching classes,
and then I
started getting requests.
People wanted to see photos of
the how-tos, and stories
behind the recipes.
So I started a blog to show
and share more recipes and
more stories.
And then I didn't know it then,
but you guys know how
the online world is a crazy
thing, and it just goes
everywhere.
It explodes.
And I started getting requests,
first from Mexicans
that were nostalgic like me, and
wanted the cookie that my
grandmother used to make,
from Zacatecas.
And she died many years ago,
and I want to make
it now for my kids.
So that's what I talk about when
I talk about the links
that are missing in the chain.
But then I started getting
other requests from other
people that weren't
even Mexican.
I got this email from a
woman in Australia.
She grows her own chiles.
And then she pickles them
and she makes salsas
and she sells them.
And she said, great
about your site.
Now can you help me?
And want to make chipotles
in adobo sauce.
I can't find them here, and
people really love them.
And I want to make them
and sell them.
Can you help me source
a recipe?
And I thought, who on Earth
would want to make the
chipotles in adobo sauce?
It's like trying to make
your own ketchup.
Like you wouldn't do that on
a Sunday night, right?
Like you go to a fancy
restaurant that has its own
homemade ketchup, but it's not
something that every people
wants to do.
So I thought, you know, you can
buy them online, and it's
not something that people
really make.
She was really insistent, and
she said, no, but I really
want to make them on my own.
Can you please help
me research?
And this is something
I love doing.
Like when somebody sends me a
request, it's like they sent
me on a mission.
So I started researching
in all my cookbooks.
And as all my family now knows,
I am obsessed with
cookbooks and cooking manuals
and anything that
has a recipe on it.
Whenever they come visit, they
bring me cookbooks from all
over Mexico.
The last one my dad brought
was a book from Colima--
which is a state in Mexico
that is really not
well-known--
about how to cook iguana
in 200 ways.
[LAUGHTER]
PATI JINICH: So that's--
I don't cook iguana.
But it's been a really
fascinating
read, let me tell you.
But so I come through all my
cookbooks, couldn't find a
recipe for chipotle
in adobo sauce.
So when I went to Mexico,
I would try to find out.
Because people pickle chipotles
in vinegar, but
guys, that's a different
thing.
That's a different recipe, OK?
So I told her I had found
recipes for chipotles pickled
in vinegar, but not in adobo.
OK.
You know what?
I'm going to stop trying
to find it somewhere.
I'm going to try and play
with it in my kitchen.
Four frustrated years later--
[LAUGHTER]
PATI JINICH: It wasn't that I
was all the time playing with
those chipotle in adobe sauce,
but every couple months, I
would try a new tweak on the
recipe here and there
until I nailed it.
And that's when I realized that
what my recipe had been
missing for all of those tries--
a little more vinegar,
a little less vinegar--
aside from a little bit of dark
brown sugar, it was the
ancho chiles.
Who would have thought that a
chile would love to be pickled
in another chile?
So that's for just
one ingredient.
You guys, you don't even
have to make that.
You can buy it in cans.
So here's why I think that
Mexico and the US, and Mexico
and the rest of the world--
because I think everybody
knows a taco, right?
Everybody knows, or thinks
they know, Mexican food.
So here I'm sort of inviting
people into, hey, look a
little closer.
We are very similar.
We have pastas.
We have rices.
We have soups and salads.
And they're going to give you
lots of options and things to
make at home.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to ask
you a question about--
for food enthusiasts who
actually want to touch and
feel the food, and like connect
with the ingredients
and stuff, are there culinary
tours, are there workshops and
other things that we could
get access to?
Because I feel if you do that,
you love food at a very
different level, versus just
picking up this recipe.
Like going to a supermarket,
getting the
ingredients and doing it.
Like are there resources
that folks like me and
maybe others can use?
PATI JINICH: Absolutely.
There is a ton.
In fact, in Mexico, there are
a lot of food tour companies
and food tour guides.
And it's really exploding.
I can give you--
I mean there's so many.
There's so many.
I'll tell you something.
Like for the classes that I
teach at the Mexican Cultural
Institute, and the recipes
that I do, I
really dig in deep.
Like one of the classes that I
did, that I have enjoyed the
most, was a class on vanilla.
Everybody thinks that
vanilla comes from--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PATI JINICH: Who said?
AUDIENCE: Madagascar?
PATI JINICH: Not Madagascar!
Yes, everybody thinks that
vanilla comes from Madagascar,
because they've been so
good at producing it
and marketing it.
I've never been to Madagascar,
but I know vanilla from
Madagascar.
Vanilla comes from Papantla,
from a really exotic, tropical
place in the state of
Veracruz in Mexico.
That's where vanilla
originated.
And that's the only
place where the
orchid or vanilla grew.
And it's existed since
Totonaca times.
I mean, pre-Hispanic times.
There's beautiful legends
surrounding--
you know, how did people come
up with producing vanilla?
You know that vanilla has
to be picked green?
And then it has to be sweated
in wooden boxes for 28 days
and then basked in the
sun during the day.
I mean, it's a really
complex process.
Whoever came up with it,
it's not an easy thing.
But I once taught a class,
because I try to do the myth,
and also show, hey,
we're Mexico, and
vanilla comes from here.
But now I'm here.
As my kids tell me, when we
get stopped, and they say,
where are you from?
And I say, we're Mexican.
My kids say, no, Ma,
you're Mexican.
We're American.
But I taught a class about
vanilla, and I developed a
menu that had dishes starting
from soup to dessert.
It even had the drink.
It was from the drink, salad,
soup, to dessert.
And it was like a historic
route of dishes that have
existed using vanilla, since
Totonaca times to more modern,
colonial, and to today, like
really experimental spins.
So it was like a historical
tour, and also the different
uses of vanilla.
The vanilla bean, the seeds,
if it's simmered.
I have the recipe for
a vinaigrette
with the vanilla fried.
And all the different uses of
vanilla bring out a different
facet of the ingredient,
right?
Anyway, just like me, there's
a lot of people that are
trying to showcase the cacao
in Mexico, and the vanilla,
and the coffee, in
the tequila.
And I can give you a
list of sources.
I mean, it's really booming.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
What do you think a cook that
starts working with this book
needs in his pantry?
What are the basic ingredients
you need to start cooking
Mexican food?
PATI JINICH: That's
a great question.
Beans, either black or pinto.
But you know, you can cook
them or you can buy.
I mean, I give people choices,
because I believe being in a
kitchen is all about choices.
Like I don't believe that there
should be only one way
to do something.
There's really shortcuts, and
people can decide where they
start, where they begin with.
But beans, rice, avocado
for sure.
Do you like avocado?
Chipotles in adobo sauce.
They're an utmost necessity.
So when I don't make them on
my own, I have cans in my
pantry, just in case
of an emergency.
You know, tomatoes.
You know, most of the basic
things in here are tomato,
onion, garlic.
And either jalapeno or chipotle
in adobo sauce.
Limes.
Limes are really crucial.
I was asked last week, which is
my favorite cooking tool?
And I love my comal.
My mom gave it to me, and I use
it for making tortillas,
toasting tortilla, trying
ingredients.
But you know what my favorite
kitchen tool is?
My lime squeezer.
It's a powerful tool.
I got it in a market
in Mexico, and
it's super heavy metal.
And it'll squeeze the
juice of any lime.
But you know, it's just fresh
ingredients like that.
And if you want to try
more of the recipes
in here, ancho chiles.
They're easy to find,
dried ancho chiles.
I would say queso fresco,
or farmer's cheese.
Last week, a food editor asked
me, and she said, Pati, I got
your book, and I love
the photos, and the
recipes look great.
But did you and your editor have
a discussion about having
a resource section, you know,
where people can find things?
And of course we had
that discussion.
But different from 50 or 40 or
30 years ago, when it was
really hard to find Mexican
ingredients, and you had one
or two brands that did
the canned stuff.
And the resource page in a
Mexican cookbook was literally
half a page.
Call this weird 1-800
number or ask your
aunt to smuggle some.
These days, if I wanted to make
a resource section to my
cookbook, it would be bigger
than the book.
Because by the time it would
have been published, it would
have been outdated.
There's so many brands
that carry
different cans of things.
From the pickled jalapenos, to
the chipotles in adobo, to the
already-cooked beans, to the
salsas, to so many things--
there's so many brands that by
the time it would have been
printed, there would be new
companies and people would be
making many things at home.
And then if I wanted a list of
stores that sell Mexican
products, I would spend the
rest of my lifetime.
And you can find
things online.
So what I do in the book, and
I really worked very hard at
it, is describing the
ingredients and giving people
the knowledge in very
simple, fast ways.
You know, you have all
these options.
How do you choose what
you bring home?
Or if you don't find something
and you really don't want to
source it-- like piloncillos,
to give you an example.
It's a fabulous Mexican
ingredient, that I would try
to find it if I were you.
Just because I like
it so much.
I put it in my coffee.
Piloncillo is the purest
form of cane sugar.
So when cane is processed, the
first-- it's like extra
virgin olive oil.
The first press of cane sugar,
it's this liquid, this cane
syrup, that is put in cones.
That's why it's called
pilon, or piloncillo.
It's put in these cones
and it dries.
And it has a beautiful,
dark caramel color.
And it's no preservatives.
Really not processed.
It tastes like a little bit like
molasses, like dark brown
sugar, but with an extra layer
of something rustic.
It tastes a little bit
like coffee, a
little bit like nuts.
It is so rich, I can't
even describe it.
There's some cookies in here
and recipes that use it.
You can sub it for
dark brown sugar.
But you find the piloncillo.
Now it's easy to find.
It goes by other names, and
I tell you [INAUDIBLE].
You'll be just having in your
pantry many more ingredients,
that not only will I--
I give you here a story, so you
know how they came to be,
what are the legends
surrounding.
Because I really think that
being in the kitchen is sort
of magical.
Like if you're cooking
with a vanilla part--
you like history.
If you're cooking with a vanilla
part, and you know the
legends and the history behind
it in an entertaining way and
you're using it, I think
connecting with that
ingredient is different.
You know?
You're here in San Francisco, in
your kitchen, and you have
this vanilla bean that
came all the
way from the Pantitlan.
You know, I just think legends
and stories and all of that
just make the cooking experience
more magical.
AUDIENCE: This is just a really
practical sort of question.
My book club is coming to my
house tomorrow and I didn't
realize it.
So I'm going to be home at 6:00
and they're all going to
arrive at 7:00.
And I've got this
new cookbook.
PATI JINICH: Today?
AUDIENCE: Tomorrow.
PATI JINICH: Tomorrow, OK.
AUDIENCE: So I can soak things
overnight or put things in the
slow cooker or in the rice
cooker or whatever.
But do you have any
ideas for me?
PATI JINICH: Of course I do!
[LAUGHTER]
PATI JINICH: Of course I do.
So many!
So there's a fabulous
pasta in Mexico--
do you like past?
Do your friends like pasta?
OK.
In Mexico, we call it
pasta seca, when the
pasta is sort of dry.
Well, it can have a sauce,
but it's not a soup.
And we call it sopa aguada
when it has broth.
And the pasta seca is--
think of a pasta al pomodoro,
but with a Mexican spin.
All you need are the
same ingredients--
pasta, a little bit of oil,
tomatoes, garlic, onion.
If you can find those
chipotle in adobo
sauce, it would be fabulous.
If not, you can use
a jalapeno.
And so you're going to cook that
pasta the Mexican way.
We cook pasta many
times like this.
You're going to break
the pasta--
either the fettuccine or angel
hair or spaghetti-- whatever
pasta you have.
It doesn't even matter.
Little stars, if you have
little stars, alphabet,
doesn't matter.
You're going to cook that pasta
in a saucepan with a
tiny little bit of oil.
But the oil has to be hot.
And you're going
add the pasta.
You're going to fry
it a little.
So this is different from the
Italians, what we do to pasta.
And there's no way that your
pasta will ever be bland.
Because you're adding
that layer of--
like when you make roux?
It's just, you're toasting
the pasta.
It's adding a layer of
depth and flavor.
And it just takes
like a minute.
And then you're going to add the
sauce, which you can make
it by pureeing tomatoes or with
a can of tomatoes, just
with some onion and garlic
and the chipotles.
You're going to add
that to the pasta.
So instead of boiling the pasta
and then adding the
sauce, think of an risotto.
It's sort of the same.
You fry the pasta for just like
a minute, and then you
add the sauce.
And the pasta cooks
in that sauce.
And so it plumps up and
cooks in sauce until
it's nice and moist.
It's incredibly delicious.
And then you add on top avocado
slices, fresh cheese.
Don't find Mexican cheese,
queso fresco?
Use a mild feta.
And it's really good.
So that--
I can give you many.
There's a great salads
in there.
I have my everyday
green salad.
You make the vinaigrette
with just a jar, you
just shake it up.
And you can do it with lettuces,
with asparagus, with
green beans, whatever
you want to use.
And you really pull
dinner in a snap.
AUDIENCE: Great, thank you.
PATI JINICH: Yeah,
my pleasure.
AUDIENCE: Thank you, Pati.
How important is it to
have good corn masa?
PATI JINICH: That's
a great question.
So I was just in Texas this
weekend, and I was at some
markets where they have their
own freshly made tortillas,
where they produce their
own fresh masa.
So I think these days--
I mean, it's fabulous if you
can find fresh corn masa.
And maybe in San Francisco,
there is.
I wouldn't tell anybody to grind
the corn and cook it for
48 hours with lime, and then
peel it, and then kneel down
on the floor, and make a masa.
It is great if you can find
somebody to do that in a
tortilleria.
But if you don't, you can buy
the corn masa flour and just
mix it with water and a
little bit of salt.
And it is really good quality.
So you can have fresh-made masa
in the fast way, which
honestly, is what Mexican
peoples do in their homes in
Mexico, when they don't have
access to a tortilleria.
Everybody uses those.
You know, Maseca or
a masa like that.
You buy it, and it's
really delicious.
So there are things in the book
where I use fresh masa.
Like there's some chochoyotes,
some dumplings, that go into a
very easy yellow mole.
I also show people, if
they want to make
their own corn tortillas.
But it is not crucial.
There's a thousand gazillion
things that you can make
without fresh masa.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
PATI JINICH: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I'm from Puebla.
PATI JINICH: No!
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PATI JINICH: Oh my god.
The food in Puebla
is spectacular!
I was just there.
I had an episode on the
foods from Puebla.
AUDIENCE: Oh, cool.
PATI JINICH: OK, sorry.
AUDIENCE: I just wanted to ask
you what your favorite region
of Mexico is, in
terms of food.
PATI JINICH: That's so hard!
That's like asking me
which one of my
kids I like the most.
[LAUGHTER]
PATI JINICH: I love them all.
Well, I love the food
from Puebla.
Love.
And I think it is really one
example of the Baroque period
in Mexico, where so many
elements got intertwined.
You know, the native Mexican
and the Spanish nuns.
I mean, we owe so much
to them, right?
Las tortitas de Santa Clara, the
mole sauces, all of that.
I love the food from Puebla.
I love the food from
Michoacan.
And I think it is a cuisine
that is not so well-known.
And it's simpler than the
food from Puebla,
but it is very unique.
It has a very defined
personality.
And it's simple and
it's super homey.
And every chance I get,
I go to Michoacan.
But then again, funny thing
is being away--
so when I lived in Mexico City,
we used to go to certain
places for vacation in Mexico.
Either Acapulco, or
Valle de Bravo.
Or you know, you don't move so
much throughout the country.
It's like here in the US, I
don't know if people really,
how many people go across the
country and try to go to every
single state.
But being in the US has made me
really hungry to learn much
more about my own country.
So any chance I get with my
family, any vacation, we'll go
to somewhere where
we haven't been.
You know, a different place
in the Yucatan Peninsula.
So not Yucatan, but Campeche.
We just took this trip from
Chihuahua to Los Mochis.
Have you gone to el
Canon del Cobre?
So beautiful.
That train, El Chepe, one
full wagon is a kitchen.
So as you're rocking back and
forth in the rails, they're,
like, squeezing the juice and
making your coffee and making
your huevos rancheros.
It's really incredible.
And so we got to eat the food
from the north, and the
chilorio, and the machaca,
and the--
so I didn't answer
your question.
I'm sorry.
Mexico City.
I love the food from
[LAUGHTER]
PATI JINICH: That's
where I grew up.
Because in Mexico City, you have
the combination of the
really metropolitan,
up-and-coming, modern trends.
New things, you know, chefs
that have fabulous
restaurants, that are really
revolutionizing Mexican cuisine.
But then you have this influx
of people from all over the
country that are coming because
they want to find
better opportunities
or they want to get
into the food world.
And they bring into the city all
these regional foods that
haven't been so well-known.
So I think Mexico City--
which is taken, I think, many
times as just a stop to go
into other places--
shouldn't be taken
for granted.
The food is fabulous, and
the museums, too.
The food.
AUDIENCE: Can you tell a
little bit about your
experiments with other cuisines
and how you try to
fuse that with Mexican?
PATI JINICH: Yes.
Other cuisines or other
ingredients?
Other cuisines?
AUDIENCE: Cuisines, if you
took a spin on it.
PATI JINICH: Oh, Italian.
I love Italian food.
I've been playing a lot with
pasta, 'cause I have a thing
with pasta.
I love pasta.
I've been playing just with
pasta a lot, like making
different kinds of lasagna.
I have a friend who taught
me a trick to make
lasagna with chilorio.
Who knows chilorio?
No?
OK.
Chilorio is in here.
You guys have to make it.
Chilorio is a dish--
similar like the
chicken tinga.
You can make it, you know,
ahead of time.
You can make it fast.
It's pork meat-- but you
can use chicken--
that's cooked in orange juice.
Can you imagine just
how good that is?
And after the meat is cooked,
you either leave it in chunks
or shred it.
And then it's finished off
in an ancho chile sauce.
So you get sort of like a sloppy
joe feeling, that has--
I mean, just think about it.
It's the meat cooked in citrus
and then chile and tomato and
a little bit of vinegar
and spices.
Think, that layered in
between pasta sheets.
It's really good.
But what I mostly play with,
really, is just like Mexican
ingredients and different
things,
different ways to use them.
LIV WU: Well, if nothing else,
you've got us hungry again.
[LAUGHTER]
LIV WU: Thank you so much.
PATI JINICH: Thank you so
much for having me.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]